you
a group of Stoneman Douglas high school
students is at the center of a teen LED
revolution this morning we go inside the
making of a movement for safer schools
CBS cameras begin following David Hogg
Mo Gonzales Kamran kasky and Delaney
Tarr from one of their first meetings to
behind closed doors with lawmakers they
are organizing this month's march for
our lives and ultimately want lawmakers
to pass meaningful reforms good morning
on this Wednesday a roller coaster of
emotions as teachers and staff welcomed
students last back in session it
Stoneman Douglas heard more gunshots and
that was when we realized this was not a
drill in case I died I wanted to die
doing what I love most which is
informing people in telling stories we
didn't start the rally but there were
people joining us so that we were
sitting there and just started showing
up then all of a sudden it turned into a
rally and that was cool we are going to
be the reason this is going to be the
last one is because this is the first
real time that we're making a political
difference my advice to you is to stay
on message and and keep following your
passion we're not trying to take away
the guns of people who are hunting and
that's something that we definitely need
to clarify any White House contacts I've
been calling like every number I could
find and all of them don't answer
why are we calm down
[Music]
[Music]
the big story tonight continues to be
the inspiring activism children senator
Rubio can you tell me right now that you
will not accept a single donation from
the NRA
I don't have a good angle to see us
listed as these heroes as these bastions
of change it's scary
let's see Anna because we are teenagers
we are children we are not here to be
patted on the back we're doing it so
that our lawmakers will make a change
Florida lawmaker struct out a motion to
consider a bill proposing a ban on
assault rifles those people should know
that they need to enjoy their political
position of power right now because
they're gonna have it for life for much
longer
as for what we have in the future we
have the March for our lives March 24th
which is going to be amazing all the
parents are going to be bringing their
kids all the kids are going to be
bringing their parents as much as we'd
like to expect to that generation to
help us out we've kind of been doing
this ourselves and we've kind of been
you know winning we'll continue
following the students and other members
of the movement here on CBS this morning
and you can see more of these behind the
scenes moments on tonight's CBS Evening
News with Jeff Glor it is amazing what
those kids have done they have almost
single-handedly reconfigured the
landscape around gun safety and they
have to stay on it all the way to that
March because as we see from Senator
flake the polit the political forces
that have are still all in play tenacity
yeah yet they're doing it while we know
they're still dealing with such trauma
at night I saw interviews where they're
still haunted by it and they're still
sore trying to sort that out for
themselves too which makes it even more
amazing what these kids are doing
incredibly March 24 it's going to be a
very special big day